to fix Sony colors first we need to find
out what is the color cast of our own
camera Sony keeps improving their color
science with each new camera released so
it's normal to have differences from
model to model and most of it can be
corrected in camera with a couple simple
steps the easiest way is to shoot a
video with the color Checker but if you
don't have one find a car Checker image
on the internet expanding on your
computer screen and take a shot it's
important to have all the cars in the
scene so you can analyze and compare
them afterwards I'll do this with three
different cameras the Sony RX100 Mark 6
the Sony a 73 and the Sony a6700 I took
a shot with all three of them and put
them inside the Venture resolve to check
the differences on the vctor scope the
a73 is magenta casted while the RX100 is
a lot colder and shifted tosan while the
a6700 is somewhere between these two
having natural colors but with a green
cast now that we know the color cast of
our Sony cameras we can start to balance
out the colors and meesh them all
together almost perfectly only by using
the car settings and the picture profile
menu